[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 13 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale saint-quentin-en-yvelines
réfléchit à un règlement local de
publicité intercommunale un document
pour encadrer la publicité sur le
territoire et limiter la pollution
visuelle l'agglomération organisait hier
une réunion publique sur le sujet les
habitants ont pu faire part de leurs
suggestions et aussi de certaines de
leurs inquiétudes des véhicules
innovants présentés sur un lieu mythique
de l'automobile du passé l'estac a
organisé une après-midi dédié à ses
étudiants à l'autodrome de linas
montlhéry en essonne est des futurs
ingénieurs ont planché sur des projets
de nouvelles mobilités nous avons pu les
rencontrer
enfin après 22 mois de travaux l'église
notre dame en sa nativité roura voisins
le bretonneux l édifice a accueilli à
nouveau les fidèles samedi dernier du
sol au plafond en passant par les
vitraux tout a été restauré et puis
invités de ce journal jean yves dréau
bénévoles à solidarités nouvelles face
au chômage yvelines qui organise un
événement ce jeudi autour de la
reconversion professionnelle c'est tout
à l'heure dans ce journal avant de
développer tous ses titres elle s'était
faite la porte-parole de la colère des
policiers maggie et biz coupe ce qui
s'est donné la mort hier soir avec son
arme de service à son domicile de
carrières sous poissy est la gardienne
de la paix de 36 ans employé au sein de
la bac de versailles avait créé une
association suite à l'attaqué des
policiers au cocktail molotov en essonne
c'était en 2016 à la fonctionnaire était
d'ailleurs visé par une procédure
interne pour être sorti de son droit de
réserve
après cette agression plusieurs
réactions suite à ce suicide dans les
yvelines celle du président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier il fait part
de sa tristesse et salue une policière
engagée et passionnée elle et lui a
réaffirmé son soutien aux forces de
l'ordre
comment encadrer la publicité sur un
territoire de 230 mille habitants c'est
la question à laquelle tente de répondre
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération prépare un règlement
local de publicité intercommunale qui
pourrait être appliquée dès 2020 et les
orientations ont été présentés
hier lors d'une réunion publique à la
salle communautaire attrape reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et de patrick
jacques de dixmude la publicité urbaine
au coeur d'une réunion publique ce lundi
12 novembre saint quentin en yvelines a
présenté à cette occasion ses premiers
travaux sur son futur règlement local de
publicité intercommunale c'est un texte
important pour le cadre de vie des
habitants et donc je devais aussi
concerté l'ensemble des acteurs que ce
soit les habitants les acteurs
économiques ou les acteurs qui milite
pour la protection de l'environnement
pour essayer d'avoir un texte finalement
qui soit équilibrée et et qui convienne
à tout le monde
plusieurs axes ont été proposées au
cours de cette soirée pour encadrer
cette publicité urbaine à l'horizon 2020
les objectifs sont clairs réduit le
format publicitaire sur le territoire
avec la proposition qui est faite
de passer de 12 m² à 8 mètres carrés
pour ce qui concerne la publicité c'est
une proposition qui est en cours de
discussion c'est aussi la volonté
d'imposer des règles de densité qui
seraient plus stricts que la
réglementation nationale
malgré ces propositions certains
habitants présents dans la salle reste
sceptique sur ce futur règlement ils ont
pu faire part de leurs inquiétudes
très clairement notre plus grosse
crainte et puis on l'a vu ce soir il ya
eu beaucoup de commentaires là dessus
c'est les écrans numériques qui est un
nouveau type de dispositif publicitaire
très agressif et énergivore en plus dont
l'implantation apparemment et tourner
quand même sur beaucoup de zones sur
l'agglomération
d'autant plus que les dimensions même si
on va à les réduire pour tout ce qui est
affichage a dû 12 m par du 8 mètres
carrés
la cen sad sous-tend qu'on va pouvoir un
peu en tête des écrans numériques de 8
mètres carrés disque est énormissime les
dossiers de concertation sont
disponibles dans l'es12 mairies de
l'agglomération vous avez jusqu'au 1er
semestre 2010 9 pour donner votre avis
dans l'actualité du jour michel
fourniret devant les assises de
versailles le tueur en série comparé
dans un procès qui doit durer quatre
jours
celui que l'on surnomme le boucher des
ardennes est accusé d'avoir accusé
pardon du meurtre de farida hammiche
commis à clairefontaine en 1988 crime
révélé en 2004 et dont le corps n'a
jamais été retrouvé michel fourniret
pourrir purge actuellement une peine de
perpétuité pour onze meurtres avoués son
nom est cité dans plusieurs autres
affaires le sport pour lutter contre
l'obésité solution avancée notamment par
le dispositif sport sur ordonnance des
séances prescrites par des médecins dans
le sud yvelines une convention a été
signée entre le club de tennis de
saint-arnoult et l'hôpital pédiatrique
et de rééducation de bullion les
explications de patrick jacques de
dixmude et de manon baratte en reprendre
confiance en soi faire du sport quand on
est attendent au b zitte et c'est
l'objectif de l'hôpital pédiatrique et
de rééducation de bullion
pendant trois mois des enfants surcharge
pondérale participent à leur programme
une convention de partenariat avec
l'union sportive de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines a été signée
afin que les enfants pratiquent le
tennis
conseiller en cas de surcharge pondérale
l'âge faire de bullion donc il ya 107
enfants qui sont qui peuvent être
accueillis au sein de l'hôpital de
bullion avec des hospitalisations
complètes mais aussi des séjours
notamment pour les enfants en situation
de surcharge pondérale sur un trimestre
avec un projet d'éducation thérapeutique
vraiment particulier donc là c'est le
premier jour de l'année dont qui fait
septembre à décembre mais il y aura
d'autres jeunes qui viendront donc de
janvier à mars et ensuite d'avril à juin
donc chaque séjour pourra bénéficier de
cette opération là les jeunes se
regroupent et chaque semaine et pratique
le tennis durant 1h30
c'est la première fois qu'on met ça en
place ce qui est vraiment intéressant
sébastien public est complètement
différent du public qu'on a
habituellement donc pour nous c'est un
challenge de réussir à les intéresser à
l'activité
les enfants hospitalisés change de cadre
en pratiquant au sein du club de tennis
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ils sont
emmenés en mini bus depuis l'hôpital
c'est vrai concentrerait on sort pas
beaucoup donc c'est pas mal de sortir un
peu de prendre l'air et
de venir faire du sport autre part que
dans le centre le sport en fait c'est la
clé c'est ce qui nous ce qu'on a besoin
en fait pour se dépenser et pour
résister de prendre du poids ces enfants
surcharge pondérale reprennent goût au
sport et continueront en dehors du
centre moi je trouve ça très bien moi
j'aime bien faire
j'en ai fait dans mon école et bah ça me
plaît je vais peut-être poursuivre si
mary du tennis un projet futur socio
éducative sera mis en place cette année
proposer des cours de tennis aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
un événement dédié à la reconversion
professionnelle il se déroule ce jeudi à
15 novembre au château de buc
reconversion une piste pour rebondir
une journée organisée par l'association
snc pour en parler en plateau jean yves
dréau bonsoir vous êtes bénévole au sein
de sncf line sncc solidarités nouvelles
face au chômage il vous est également le
coordinateur de cette journée organisée
jeudi on va présenter avec vous cet
événement déjà présenté nous cette
association
qu'est-ce que snc quelles sont ses
missions nouvelles face au chômage et on
a donc une partie d'associations
nationales avec 200 groupes en france
2500 bénévoles et 4000 personnes qui
sont accompagnés donc qui sont au
chômage et qui sont accompagnés tous les
ans avec un taux de retour en activité
de 64%
c'est une fois que vous avez accompagné
ces personnels retrouve elle retourne
vers l'emploi elle retrouve une activité
donc soit effectivement à trouver un cdi
soit à cdd de plus de six mois soit
allemand de leur entreprise soit le
trouve une formation de longue durée
alors quelles actions sont mises en
place alors particulièrement pour le
coup sur le territoire des yvelines
alors juste rappeler que dans les
yvelines on a neuf groupes avec 130
bénévoles et on accompagne 371 personnes
et cette année le taux de reprise
activités de 68% pratiquement 70%
notre question c'était sur les actions
déployées
les actions ont fait plusieurs choses
donc là
la première c'est d'accompagner les
personnes donc on le fait en binôme en
fait donc il ya deux personnes bénévoles
qui vont accompagner un chômeur et donc
il ya un gros travail d' écoute je
dirais active de la personne serait
souvent des personnes qui sont au
chômage depuis longtemps qu'ils sont
dans une spirale négative et qu'il faut
remonter d'accord donc l'écouter est
importante leur redonner confiance et
donc on va les accompagner à raison de
une heure une heure et demie tous les
quinze jours le temps qu'il faudra et
voulait d'iliad et plusieurs groupes
locaux dans les yvelines notamment à
versailles est aussi sur le territoire
de saint quentin
tout en yvelines alors revenons on a
également des ateliers c'est qu'on fait
des ateliers pour préparer les
chercheurs d'emploi à trouver du travail
atelier d'organisation de son travail
atelier bilan de compétences atelier cv
lettre de motivation
atelier entretiens de recrutement et
ateliers entretien réseau et pour les
avoir personnellement testé si je puis
dire c'est du bon niveau d'accord en
revenons à l'événement de jeudi s'est
dédié à la reconversion professionnelle
et c'est un thème c'est important de le
préciser jean yves le drian qui concerne
tout le monde qu'on soit jeunes actifs
seniors cela concerne tout le monde la
reconversion professionnelle tout à fait
elle concerne tout le monde et elle
concernera de plus en plus de monde dans
la mesure où on arrive dans une ère où
il ya la révolution numérique qui fait
que pratiquement tous les métiers de
demain n'existe pas aujourd'hui donc
c'est vrai qu'il y aura forcément chacun
sera amené à vivre une reconversion
il y avait une enquête de l'afpa de 2014
je crois qu'il montrait que déjà en 2014
soixante pour cent des gens avaient fait
une reconversion est-ce que c'est
compliqué aujourd'hui de faire une
reconversion professionnelle
il faut pas se leurrer c'est pas simple
ça peut prendre entre 6 et 36 mois et
effectivement il faut quand je veux me
reconvertir ou bien se poser la question
c'est est ce que je veux vraiment me
reconvertir ou est ce que c'est juste
gérer l'entreprise dans laquelle il
travaille qui me convient plus est donc
là je change d'entreprise
mais je garde le même métier
mais je peux être aussi amené à vouloir
changer de métier ou être j'agirai
contraint par un licenciement économique
ou autre à changer de métier donc c'est
pas la même chose c'est bien qu'une
réflexion avoir alors pourquoi organisé
justement ces deux journées jeudi c'est
pour donner toutes les clés aux
personnes qui se posent des questions
qu'ils souhaitent s'orienter vers cette
reconversion tout à fait donc on au roi
des experts dans le domaine des gens de
pôle emploi
des bénévoles de chez nous il y aura des
gens de commandes de la pépinière
d'entreprises de versailles
et puis il y aura également des gens de
lui et même temps des gens qui
connaissent bien la reconversion
une table ronde qui va expliquer
effectivement ce que c'est ce que ça
n'est pas et comment il faut s'y prendre
ça va durer à peu près une heure et
demie avec des questions donc en gros
trois quarts d'heure d'exposer et une
heure et des trois quarts d'heure de
questions voilà donc voix se poser des
question c'est est-ce que je veux
changer de métier ou est-ce que je garde
le même métier et dans ce cas là je veux
juste monter mon entreprise par exemple
quelles sont les compétences que je
possède d'où l'intérêt de faire un bilan
de compétences qu'elles sont après un
bilan de compétences les pistes que je
peux je peux explorer aussi quelles sont
mes envies ou mes projets parce que je
pouvais a envie de faire quelque chose
passionné par quelque chose et du coup
et ben voila je vais dans une direction
où j'ai pas forcément les compétences
qui vont bien et là je me poserai la
question de la formation d'accord quelle
formation j'aurais besoin pour pouvoir
me reconvertir derrière ce qui se poser
la question du coût parce qu'une
formation ça dure je sais pas trois mois
six mois voire plus a un coût est-ce que
je peux la financer est-ce que je peux
me faire aider par pôle emploi ou par ou
par la région est-ce que j'ai besoin de
faire accompagner
on a compris un programme très complet
on arrive déjà malheureusement à la fin
de cet entretien
je voulais juste ajouté il ya un autre
événement qui se prépare c'est un
événement autour du chômage et de la
santé c'est tout à fait c'est aussi à
quelque chose qui est d'actualité
on se rend compte au niveau de la snc
que la santé enfin le chômage a un
impact énorme sur la santé et donc on va
les organiser un événement pratiquement
similaire en mars avril sur le
le sujet chômage et santé merci jean
yves derai ou d'avoir été avec nous le
rappelle que vous êtes bénévole aux
siens au sein de snc yvelines
coordinateur de cette journée qui se
déroulera donc ce jeudi 15 novembre pour
contacter l'association avoir d'autres
informations sur cette thématique je
vous invite à vous rendre sur les liens
qui s'affiche en bas de cet écran
accueilli en tout cas des cours de
sciences dans la langue de shakespeare
le rectorat de l'académie de versailles
s'est associé au british council pour
participer au programme ça use in
schools la première s classe européenne
du lycée jules ferry de versailles a pu
suivre une séance en anglais sur place
marie ligne à pishin on apprendre à
calculer l'âge de l'univers en anglais
le lycée jules ferry accueilli miles
oddsson un professeur de sciences
physiques britannique pour un atelier
d'astronomie
c'est un programme du british council
l'idée est de donner plus de regrets aux
étudiants mais pas seulement des cours
d'anglais
on suppose qu'il est plus intéressant
pour eux d'apprendre l'anglais sans
savoir qu'on a trop l'anglais
les premières s sections européennes ont
également pu déchiffrer les messages
adressés aux extraterrestres on était
vraiment acteur aux élus strict stop il
y avait des ateliers en fait manuel
qu'on n'a pas encore normal s'expliquer
en anglais donc moi au début on sait ne
pas trop comprendre mais finalement
c'était le british council services
britanniques pour les relations
culturelles à l'international propose
son programme saillantes si schools
depuis dix ans le principe faire venir
un enseignant britannique pour donner un
atelier scientifique aux élèves et
dirigé une master class avec les
professeurs c'est le gaz est aussi après
de faire des échanges collaboratifs on
espère après ce dur et sur un plus long
terme et pourquoi pas ne pas le
réinviter l'année prochaine ou pour
d'autres sessions sur d'autres sujets
serait très intéressant l'académie de
versailles accueille ces ateliers dans
quatre établissements différents essais
lors d'un rendez vous hebdomadaire on
retrouve mélanie poquet bon soir votre
coup de coeur et musicale cette semaine
mélanie on le surnomme la tortue depuis
son passage dans l'émission à la
nouvelle star et pour sa nouvelle
tournée il passe par montigny le
bretonneux et oui christophe willem est
en concert ce week end le samedi 7
novembre à la fin du manet l'occasion de
découvrir les 12 titres de son album le
cinquième
rio est sorti en septembre 2010 est
l'artiste parcourt la france depuis le
mois de mars cette année
pour ce nouvel album christophe willem
signe la quasi totalité des textes
accompagnés par le chanteur y goûte on
en a l'habitude à christophe willem
s'est toujours des titres plein de bonne
humeur pour cet album toujours plus de
pop alors si c'est la ville de rio de
janeiro qui l'inspiré pas de carnaval
pas de samba pas de bossales de vay
parle des travers de l'épeuve des
messages et nous sur les réseaux sociaux
il a lui-même connu cette situation
janvier 2016 il ferme son compte twitter
lassé des critiques et des commentaires
injurieux
il faut donc passer au dessus de la
musique et bien prêter l'oreille aux
paroles vous pouviez notamment vous
laisser porter par un titre plus doux
comme une ballade aller à la rencontre
de madame le maire brisé christophe
willem rend hommage à latifa india ten
la merde imad l'une des victimes de
mohamed merah christophe willem est donc
en concert à la ferme du manet de
montigny-le-bretonneux malheureusement
c'est déjà complet mais pas d'inquiétude
il revient dans l'est
yveline c'est le 5 décembre et il sera
sur la scène du théâtre alexandre dumas
à saint germain en laye merci mélanie
pour cette chronique votre émission le
7-8 culture à suivre après ce journal
avec plein d'autres sujets après vingt
deux mois 22 mois de travaux les
paroissiens de voisins-le-bretonneux
retrouvent leur église entièrement
rénovée elle a été inaugurée samedi en
musique
marylène iapichino ses portes sont enfin
ouvertes
il n'a pas fallu moins de 22 mois pour
que l'église de voisins-le-bretonneux
retrouve une deuxième jeunesse 22 mois
de restauration c'est une épreuve pour
une paroisse ces 22 mois de dispersion
ses 22 mois sans trop savoir où se
réunir donc on était content que ces 22
mois se termine des travaux plus long
que prévu l'avancée des travaux a été
interrompu pour relancer des études
concernant la densité du sol un sol qui
a finalement été refait avec 30 de
micropieux pour pouvoir porter la dalle
cent mille euros se sont ajoutés aux 350
me prévus au départ un investissement
pour un you for patrimoine elle va avoir
cinq cents ans bientôt elle a eu
plusieurs vies
ça a d'abord été un lieu de culte et une
église a ensuite été un temple de la
pensée pendant la révolution française
ensuite elle a été partiellement
détruite pendant la guerre de 39-45 et
en partie reconstruite pour là il ya une
vraie double vocation à la fois là la
vocation cultuelle est à la fois la
vocation de patrimoine
du sol au plafond tout a été restauré
sans oublier les vitraux et le tableau
de sainte geneviève
l'une des trois seules représentations
de la sainte en france notre église est
formidable elle était belle à ben bella
encore plus belle maintenant j'étais
déjà très beau avant parce que dix très
ancienne qui retrouve une seconde
jeunesse sur vous ça très intéressant
est magnifique
fier de son église toute neuve la
paroisse désire désormais s'ouvrir à un
public plus large avec notamment des
concerts tous les dimanches une nouvelle
et puis sortons de ce plateau pour
refermer ce journal direction
l'autodrome de linas montlhéry en
essonne l'estaca au cours d'une
après-midi à mise en avant ces
associations étudiantes qui ont conçu
des véhicules innovants avec patrick
jacques de dixmude nous étions sur place
bol d'or grand prix de l'automobile club
de france coupes moto légende
l'autodrome de linas montlhéry en
essonne a été l'un des circuits phare en
france jusque dans les années 60
c'est sur ce lieu mythique classé
aujourd'hui patrimoine du xxème siècle
que l'estac à a présenté ses véhicules
de demain alors que les prix des
carburants à la pompe augmentent les
étudiants de l'école d'ingénieurs à
baser notamment à montigny le bretonneux
ont planché sur les nouvelles mobilités
sur les nouveaux modes de circulation se
passer du pétrole ou presque
rouler à la pile combustible ou à
l'électrique nous avons pu rencontrer
certains des concepteurs
[Musique]
et avant d'aller à la rencontre de ses
étudiants et présenter leur véhicule
innovant présentons aussi cette journée
dans sa globalité avec ce énième by
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le directeur
international et partenariats de l'estac
a déjà pourquoi organiser cette journée
ici à l'autodrome de linas montlhéry
tout simplement c'est pour mettre à
l'honneur la vie associative de notre
école ses étudiants ses partenaires ses
sponsors ses anciens élèves
donc les mettre à l'honneur voir les
véhicules en statique et en dynamique
puis bien évidemment on est accueilli
par notre partenaire industriel qui est
le groupe u tacs qui bénéficie
d'équipements prestigieux sur un circuit
centenaire un quasiment donc voilà c'est
un gros événement pour nous pourquoi
c'est important pour ces étudiants de au
sein d'associations pouvoir voilà qu'on
se concevoir des véhicules innovants
tout simplement parce que ça fait partie
de leur apprentissage
quand on est dans une association on
doit concevoir on doit chercher des
fonds on doit convaincre des sponsors et
donc pour nous à l'estaca si tout
important d'accompagner la formation on
va dire un peu plus classique en cours
en amphithéâtre avec les enseignants
avec la recherche mais évidemment la
partie associative fait partie de la
formation est bien évidemment ça
entraîne aussi la passion qui est très
importante quand on emploie et quand on
s'implique dans ce métier d'ingénieur
ce véhicule que vous voyez devant moi a
parcouru 1500 2,4 km tenez vous bien
avec un seul litre d'essence il a été
conçu par les étudiants de l'association
bébés 3e bonjour et antoine de l'est
bonjour vous êtes le président de cette
association sur le campus de l'estaca à
saint quentin en yvelines alors déjà
parlez nous un peu de cette association
vous travaillez vous à saint quentin
uniquement sur des véhicules thermiques
oui c'est ça alors c'est une association
étudiante de l'estaca donc école
d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans les
transports
voilà dont le but est de parcourir le
plus de kilomètres avec un litre
d'essence donc nous participons
historiquement à cette compétition qui
est celle que marathon pour un accueil
nous déplaçons ce soit en france à
nogaro
houas
londres lors du lors de l'été dernier
par exemple comment on peut parcourir
ces 1500 kilomètres avec un seul litre
d'essence commencent et c'est possible
alors déjà en est un moteur qui ne
consomme pas c'est vrai c'est vraiment
le nerf de la guerre en haut niveau du
shell eco marathon c'est le moteur voilà
on a également l'aérodynamique avoir un
véhicule qui pénètrent bien dans l'air
ici on voit qu'il a été particulièrement
soignée l'idée est vraiment de voilà
d'avoir le moins de résistance possible
à l'air lors du passage du véhicule est
ensuite avoir finalement une dernier
point une bonne rigidité du châssis en
lui-même qui permettent donc voilà de
perdre on perd le minimum d'énergie en
fait dans le dans le véhicule tout
entier a lors de son passage parce que
vous pensez que ce genre de véhicule
pourrait peut-être se développer à
l'avenir pour des questions voilà de
réduction de consommation d'essence est
ce qu on pourrait voir un véhicule de ce
type ou autre se développer à l'avenir
un véhicule de ce type c'est compliqué
puisqu'on va bien que voilà le pilote
n'a pas beaucoup de place on attend
beaucoup d'une voiture aujourd'hui en
termes de systèmes embarqués en termes
de climatisation et autres on peut dire
que ce type de véhicule là typiquement
ne peut pas être dans la rue demain
maintenant toutes les technologies qu'on
développe toulouse est ce qu'on peut
faire chez soi sur des nouveaux
matériaux sur des nouveaux cycles
thermodynamiques tout ça peuvent très
bien correspondre au monde de
l'automobile
au niveau plus large et donc se
retrouver demain dans l'industrie
automobile
vous l'avez vu avec le projet calypso
ces étudiants de l'estaca participe
également à des compétitions pour tester
et mettre aux prises leur véhicule c'est
le cas notamment de 7,02 une monoplace
thermique qui a été conçu par les
étudiants de le ft bonjour amis une beta
bonjour vous êtes le responsable
liaisons au sol de le ft le ftc le
l'estaca pardon formula student et vous
participez donc à une compétition qui
s'appelle la formula student ça donc
c'est une compétition internationale y
en a plusieurs notamment aux pays bas en
hongrie autriche angleterre allemagne
le but c'est de concevoir et fabriquer
une petite monoplace qui se rapproche
d'une formule 1 à l'échelle de la
étudiante est donc là on a le projet au
c02 qui a concouru lors du dernier
formula student en italie par les ont
nous on est sur du moteur thermique
c'est ça donc la wii d'encre et c'était
là la voiture de 2016
c'est un moteur thermique c'est un
monocylindre bmw donc on est et on est
en lutte est allé en italie avec ce
véhicule là et depuis on est passé à
notre véhicule ec-03 dont nous pouvons
voir quelques pièces qu'on nous avons
que nous avons ramené aujourd'hui donc
là le le passage à auchy 03 est très
important pour nous on passe dans une
autre dimension notamment point de vue
moteur on passe d'un monocylindre un
tricylindre de 450 centimètres cube à
675 centimètres cubes point de vue
châssis aussi on a un châssis et brident
dernière chose le rendez vous là pour la
formula student il est fixé à caen le
rendez vous est fixé cet été donc on
participera de compétition ce sera les
en fait les inscriptions en compétition
ce sera en mars
donc on vise pays-bas et sûrement
peut-être l'autriche
et puis sur cette journée dédiée à
l'innovation ici à l'autodrome de
montlhéry il y avait également le lien
fait avec le passé avec la présence de
ces étudiants de l'association res avec
moi le président sur le campus de saint
quentin en yvelines de l'association
rice a ux andreu denis bonjour
alors reis ça veut dire restauration
d'automobiles de collection de l'estaca
c'est quoi cette association
en fait c'est une association qui va
réunir des passionnés d'automobiles
anciennes et on va se réunir pour
travailler faire de la mécanique sur les
véhicules des étudiants donc ça peut
être des restauration complète ou alors
simplement des entretiens très pointu
qu'on va vraiment essayer de découvrir
la mécanique ensemble compléter nos
connaissances en échangeant les uns les
autres
vous êtes venu justement ici à montlhéry
et que le moteur d'une alfa romeo que
vous êtes en train de restaurer c'est ça
tout à fait donc là on a refait le
moteur intégralement pour participer aux
finales avec cette alfa romeo un rallye
donc qui s'appelle le vosges rallye
festival c'est un rallye qui en
seulement deux ans s'est imposé comme
l'un des événements majeurs du score
automobile historique en france le reste
de la voiture que ce soit les trains
roulants sont faits on n'attend plus que
de reposer le moteur dans la voiture et
ensuite ce sera toutes les finitions
remontée l'intérieur mais voilà on est
sur la plus grosse étape c'est la fin du
moteur voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire
sur cette journée du véhicule innovant
ici à l'autodrome de linas montlhéry
allez je vais prendre la route retour
dans les studios tv 78 c'est la fin du
set 8 journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]